[Music]
hi everybody I'm Dr Nick um no I'm
actually hi hi I'm actually Kevin vanord
and uh I'm seated next to Mary Kish
who's decided to be my uh my computer
person yeah I will be assisting with all
of the questions and concerns people
might have about Dying Light because as
they know there is no review yet there's
no review yet on gam.com uh there's no
review anywhere yet um that's because we
didn't get review code till um today
lately is that a word what am I saying
so but anyway and since I'm probably not
going to have a review up for tomorrow
when the game comes out this is sort of
a this is a preliminary thing we said
hey can we do a live stream and they
were like sure do a live stream so it's
kind of like a review in the making yeah
consider this a a review in progress
type thing although I've played many
hours now how far are you um I don't
know you know when you have a when of a
game that that sort of has you know the
open worldish stuff you never really
know how far you are it does keep track
of how far you are in the story though
it's sort of I guess sort of like Far
Cry in that sense where you sort of know
how far you are into the story but I get
distracted it's easy for me to do in
games like this I just get totally
distracted by you think that one day
you'll just be playing it and all of a
sudden the credits will roll and you'll
say oh well I mean most stories have
some kind of thrust right there's an arc
so it's not going to I'm not going to be
like hey will you go and uh pick me up a
pack of smokes I'm like sure I'll go and
do that for you Mission giver and come
back and say congratulations you picked
up the smokes game over usually usually
usually games have a little bit more
Nuance that be the final the final
mission is there any way we can get some
sound for the for me I I should have
asked before I didn't was going to have
sound Josh is on the case so uh if you
have any questions um the best place to
ask is uh in the twitch chat since it's
just easier to keep up there thank
thanks Josh you're the best yeah do me a
favor he's my best friend Jos he doesn't
know it we've never actually hung out
well actually that's not true we have
hung out outside of work but but uh yeah
he doesn't know that he's my best friend
if you guys do have questions for Kevin
uh go ahead and throw question in your
chat like put question the word question
first uh and then put your question that
way I can see it really easily I'll go
ahead and uh and Mary's totally rad so
you should you should really do what she
says yeah people also enjoy my company
like Josh yeah I think yeah I mean
really it all comes down to Josh
everything's about
Josh tell me are you in the middle of a
mission right now I well you're always
sort of in the middle of a mission if
you want deling pizza what are you doing
but well let's let's oops Let's uh let's
head off to where the mission is taking
me let's H give you a quick rundown
first so this is a a an open world
zombie game from techland um who make
Dead Island and therefore you might have
some idea of what to expect except
here's here's something which is I don't
really I never cared that much for for
Dead Island and I'm really enjoying this
game I you know that's a really good
question I was probably going to bring
that up as well a lot of people who
played Dead Island um I put uh many
hours into it I I didn't finish it
because I felt like the missions were
really dull and uninteresting and
repetitive well we we'll get to that in
a second um I I want to throw in too
that like the big the one of the biggest
changes of course over Dead Island is is
of course all the
parkour that mean that completely
changes the game in many ways does it
not it does sort of change the feel of
the game right um because you're moving
around and you get to do things like
this I don't know if people can hear
like there we go because the I'm playing
on PS4 and so there's dialogue that
comes through the PS4
controller so I I always kind of like
that that's a nice little
mechanic worried so you play um as a
government agent named crane um you've
been dropped into this uh this South
American
city um in order to infiltrate and get
some kind of uh
intelligence um from a from a potential
you know terrorist type dude is is the
impression but like that stuff kind of
goes away very quickly and now you're
more involved in just uh doing well
fetch Quests for the the game's two
different factions at this stage and uh
that that was the thing that was the
similarity to Dead Island that that
that's still there um and is probably my
biggest problem right now is that you
really are just like oops that was not
well done um on my part um so but but
you you do end up sort of being an
errand boy all of the time and it it can
get a little Annoying the good news is
that being out there in the open
open world there's a lot of sense of uh
like you know the movement's just fun
it's there are times where I'm like God
I really want to get to the other side
of the map and I I kind of wish I didn't
have to jump so like to to walk and run
so much to get there I wish um there was
something a little bit quicker do you
feel like it um I've heard from several
people that the game feels a little slow
at the beginning it's slow at the
beginning picks up and it does pick up I
mean you that guy on the other hand this
is
game oh hi he popped up so this is a
techland game so it does come with that
uh
peculiarly I I call it wonk that oops
hello on the other hand you can drop
kick zombies the drop kicking is really
fun it seems it's my favorite thing to
do showed you a skeleton it's because I
oh that guy is always tough guys like
that are always tough the reason is
because that's you you know you're
stunning a dude when you see that um so
when you see that particular effect that
means you've stunned zombies but like
staying on the move is is really
important like you can stick around and
and uh and hammer on them if you want
but there's weapon degradation and so
you do that enough and and it's just and
they're going to keep coming it's not
like you can rid them they'll just keep
spawning so you might as well only kill
them when you need always zombies but
sometimes it's good to like get supplies
right so there's there's um obviously
things you can find to make better
weapons better items um I'm getting a
question are there ways to augment your
Mobility uh yes in fact this let's let's
take a moment and step back and go into
the menu and I'll show you all sorts of
things you can do okay actually pretty
in intimidating menu there's a lot of
different stuff to do here so here's
here's the map that I've that I've been
to so far all these are safe houses um
which are zombie free spaces essentially
but you have to liberate them think of
them like Far Cry 3 far cry 4's Towers
like you have to go in sometimes you
actually do have to climb a really tall
tower and it's a lot more excruciating
than in Far Cry 3 and Far Cry 4 because
man they get really tall and it's so
easy to like Miss a jump and go tumbling
to the bottom so and then you have to
start all the way from the beginning
what's this red one that means that
you've seen that means I haven't cleared
this one yet the green ones I've cleared
the red ones I have not so quests that's
whatever we all know what that means so
here's my inventory
um you've got your basic weapons and you
can modify them and actually craft more
if you want so here is for example um a
knife that I've modified okay and you
can sort of look at it and see what
modifications I've added to it like
stuff that improves handling damage
durability and so on and so forth so uh
I haven't even used this yet so I'm
looking forward I'll just switch over to
this weapon in a minute and we can take
a look and see how it's like
how it's Exquisite it says so you know
because it's right there in the name um
so yeah and then you collect valuables
this is just for selling this is like
RPG trash basically okay um and these
are like the parts you use to craft
stuff and you do that in the blueprints
menu and you can see here all the
blueprints that I've found and earned
and so far um let's uh let's make a
Molotov because they're really
helpful um and you can also uh create
throwing stars at this point there's
probably a lot more throwing weapons
that I haven't gotten there's actually
an upgrade too for throwing a melee
weapon but I haven't taken that upgrade
yet let's uh choose the exploding
throwing stars are awesome and amazing
to use because sometimes I I'll just use
one and we'll see if it happens but
sometimes a zombie just goes flying into
the air like it's it's just amazing to
behold and I forgot skills this is this
this goes down to the question that was
asked originally and here we are so
there are three types of skills um you
you level them up by doing the things
that are related to them so Survivor
skills you you you know skill points you
earn by essentially like collecting
stuff um Power is done by you know
combat and Agility is by moving around
the world in lots of interesting ways um
so like here you you know the very thing
you start with is like a chance to stun
when you use a blunt weapon um I can do
multiple throws when I have different
weapons or different throwing weapons
and I forgot that I had that I've never
used it I better start working on that
um this is the kick multiple exploding
Stars yeah all at one time like to
different enemies so I haven't even used
that I forgot I I used I I I got that um
and some other more passive passive
things obviously I haven't gotten that
far um in that stuff but uh we'll go
back
agility um this is where I like leveling
up most because uh so so for example
this is where I got my slide you can
slide um and then eventually you unlock
the option to uh break enemies legs when
you slide into them um so that's pretty
cool what can you see can you see ah
head into the future of the other things
that you'll be likely to get you know a
lot of times when you do skill trees you
don't you don't look at what you're
getting next you look at where you want
to be yeah um my problem though is that
everything sounds kind of cool and so so
I'm just like yeah I'm gonna I'm just
going to take whatever seems cool at the
time and then I'll figure it out as I go
let's I want to see what's in the expert
level the last let's go down so um this
is just passive upgrade like you run
longer climb more quickly Etc ET without
getting tired right this lets you run up
a wall or other flat surfaces even after
jumping God what I wouldn't give to have
that now health regen pretty
self-explain and ultimate Runner which
is the best free runner so it looks like
the ultimate stuff is all mostly just
passive stuff all right well let's see a
really but uh when grabbed you can shake
off biters more quickly instant Escape
allows you to break free
instantly um looks like here reducing
fall damage um forward rolls here's one
that I actually want and haven't taken
and I want it because you don't just
fight zombies sometimes you fight like
looters and stuff like that and they're
they're a lot more they're a little
trickier to to deal with and so vaulting
over them would be really helpful
because they'll actually like slide back
and forth and stuff like that away from
you so I think that's what I'll take the
next time I get an upgrade so yeah it
seems really good for being elusive as
well at night cuz uh we haven't seen
this part yet we're currently in the day
I'll try to get there though but it
looks like at night you're not fighting
you're running you are fighting
sometimes but it's best to just not get
involved in something it's only it's
9:36 in the morning though right now so
hopefully we'll get a chance to get
tonight you can actually sleep um sleep
until night time or sleep until daytime
so maybe I'll I'll end up doing that but
so that's what you're looking at for for
the upgrades is stuff is is three
different trees and within that there's
actually a lot of room like as you see I
didn't have to choose everything AC like
you know linearly like I got to choose
you know you have to choose certain
things to unlock new stuff they have to
be connected yeah they're connected but
you can like if I don't want to gain the
other connected stuff then I can just
move on and do other stuff if those
things don't interest me all
right so uh yeah Prince do you have to
learn those or do you just once you have
them you know you buy them or you find
them in the environment okay what do
they cost are you talking about like
buying for like bits of food and canned
goods or money is there um a money
system in this how does it work yes
there's absolutely so here's when you
first land this is this is the tower
okay and these are the people that
initially uh that initially take you in
um but soon you become I won't say
double agent but soon you become sort of
working on behalf of both factions in
order to help the people in the tower
see the thing is they need antisin and
that's that's a medicine that helps keep
them from turning into zombies you've
also been infected you as crane you've
been infected here is the Quarter Master
um you pick up surv like if you get to
survival drops sometimes planes will
come across the map and drop um survival
supplies and if you pick them up and
bring them back to the Quarter Master
he'll do stuff and he always has free
stuff to give you every day as long as
you go back to him sometimes I forget to
go back to the tower that's interesting
that's an interesting mechanic to keep
you to keep you going back yeah so uh
let's talk to him on that's a nice
screen it's an interesting it's an
interesting uh transition especially
because the first time you take the
elevator you don't see that transition
you actually just get into the elevator
and then the now like every time you get
in it just like paint going down the the
screen and stuff weird but uh but yeah
if you have any questions let me know I
don't know yeah I'm getting a few in uh
someone wants to know what the touchpad
does on the PS4 um it opens up the menu
the main menu as far as I know it
doesn't do anything interesting the only
the only um yeah that's all it does o I
have a skill point to spend too I didn't
even realize that let's spend that real
quick so help me let let's live it up to
the the twitch chat to decide all right
um so I've got give us some options
Master Backpacker which lets me carry
more stuff in my backpack okay um Bo
booster XL okay so you can make boosters
again it's sort of like Far Cry where
you can make boosters that enhance um
like survivability and vision and things
like that for a period of time um I'm
not really I haven't really done much
with that lower prices in shops um
electric fences opens up electric fence
traps so sometimes you want to lure
zombies into traps to make them die that
way um and lucky repair which is getting
better at repairs um I assume
everybody's going to go for the electric
fence because
you know it's the most interesting for
people that are watching the game as
opposed to I mean I I personally I don't
know if I'm allowed to have a vote but I
would go with electrocution immediately
okay what what calling you the master
big people like Master backpack more
backpack electric fences put in your
votes I'm just going to read them out a
little bit backpack is winning right
it's between backpack and fence for sure
we'll do backpack then so this this uh
gives me six more slots for in weapons
so I'll go ahead and do that I mean it
will be good to like kind of see the
variety of weapons I still would really
like to see a knife um and that
exploding star so that I use that stuff
so right now I've got a knife a hammer a
wrench and and another Hammer a claw
hmer so I assume you hold that one
backwards right like you're going to
take out you're asking me too much to
notice things I want to know let's go
over to blueprints real quick too um I
think I have I already did some throwing
weapons right so another another set of
molotovs you're not just making one
Molotov by the way you're making one set
of molotovs and then you can increase
that as you that's some of the other
leveling things is that like hey you
make more molotovs or more throwing
stars when you when you do a Molotov
creation so have you um do you have like
fine comparisons with this with State of
Decay I never play State of Decay so I
feel like that's uh that's that's
not good for me to bring that one up
because I I honestly don't know all
right let's try what about Co-op have
you played this with any yet I I've
tried um the problem is that there's no
nobody's bought the game yet but enough
people have managed to get a hold of the
game um out in the wild from retailers
selling it before they're supposed to
and stuff like that of there's sort of
an invasion mechanic where somebody can
play the Monster when I get um and
invade your world and then there's this
whole thing where the team of moners
sort of yeah and then but it's team
based then and so you've got a team of
monsters that try to come after the team
of reg of normals I guess but that's not
campaign mode that's a separate mode no
it happens all in within the game like
if you open it up to the game you can be
doing stuff with like your Co-op buddies
or alone and suddenly it will just
happen and now suddenly you've got like
a multiplayer thing happening within the
game and what that
entails when it happens is the normals
have to go out and kill like the they
have to go out and kill like these weird
creatures these these creatures that
that allow the the other players to
spawn and the other players come after
you to kill you before you can before
you can do that but they can like pounce
on you and kill you in like one hit and
then you use your ultraviolet flashlight
to uh to damage them and make them more
vulnerable so so where are we right now
what are you doing so right now I'm I'm
in the tower I'm I'm getting some quests
done so I'm going to hurry up and try to
do this so I can get back into the world
yeah this part's boring
you'd be surprised though nothing is
would you find this game would you say
it's tense are you yes there are moments
that are sometimes it's boring um and
some but mostly not that that's very
rare that I'm like gosh again the boring
part is like you're just you're just
running errands for everybody and and I
feel like after so after this being such
a problem in Dead Island over multiple
games that maybe they could you know mix
it up a little bit but for now that's
that's the the boring part the fun part
is sometimes the tension is just
incredible like you have to run missions
and then you have to uh get in the
middle of zombies and nighttime is
something completely different um
nighttime
comes um and then you and then the uh
the nastiest zombies they're really fast
and during the daytime you want to avoid
um getting their attention by making
lots of noise but at night time they
have Vision cones and as soon as they
see you they'll just start coming and
running after
you um it's so there are moments where
I'm just like oh my god um how am I
going to get out of this mess it's not
like Daisy type stress like what's
happening over to that to the right with
those people over there that's just some
zombie what do they do when you're
around you just dig on the ground um
well those dudes they they just kind of
do zombie things uh can you kill them
yeah totally
let's this again this is my favorite
thing to do with the zombies is to drop
kick straight up drop kick I'd like to
see some Hammer action oh Hammer action
okay
Hammer
action as far as I know there's no
manual mode like in in Dead Island you
you could sort of oh CRA oh they're
behind you this is what happens when you
engage is like all of the nearby ones
and then if you make too much noise the
really nasty ones come out how about um
oh see the drop Kick's so good because
it it makes them move away whereas when
you're hammering they're still really
close to you I just broke that one's
legs that took away a lot of
Health yeah what's your health 100 point
scale it's a 100 point scale um oh [__]
and then each bite looks like it takes
about 20 away so it's now the there's a
sort of a Health replenish hang on I've
got molotovs this will help do it oh no
that's uh that's basically a I think you
just threw a bottle of liquor at them no
it's a thing where I I basically throw
like fuel on the ground and then I have
to set it a light I didn't I thought I
had something different equipped I
thought I had a Molotov equipped but
Molotov super helpful as you can
see 17 bucks oh that was dumb of me all
right let's oh there's a guy behind you
oh she's um she's one of the fast
climber
types holy crap they are
fast a get off of me this is what
happens like kind of when you engage is
like you're you're not meant to do that
you're you're meant mostly just parkour
away yeah I mean it's it's about it's
more about you're using all your
mtops oh it's more about getting away
and staying safe than it is engaging
them I mean sometimes I still want the
supplies that they might have what what
kind of goodies do you find you know
like in Day Z sometimes you can find or
like H1Z1 you can find zombies that have
significant weapons on them making it
worthwhile it's not always but like
sometimes you can get a zombie that's
got like like guns on them and bullets
and that's super helpful okay I'm
running and you haven't found um you
don't have any guns right now right you
just have no I I I uh I don't there's a
side quest early on that I still haven't
done to get a gun for a dude but I don't
know when gu is
terrifying suck Hammer oh I have to
Let's uh let's use that special knife
that I've made and have it used do you
ever feel like you get motion sickness
from all the movement yes so this is a
not not greatly but this is something to
keep in mind if you play um especially
if it happened when you played Mirror's
Edge which it never happened to me when
it played Mirror's Edge so I think that
kind of it's it's rare now at first it
seemed to be happening a lot but part of
the problem with that is that the
initial cut scene oh there's somebody to
to uh to rescue over
here how did you see that it's on your
yeah it was on my map it's like one of
those like quick time events where
because you're in the area yeah see in
the in the on the mini map where he's
blue I have to I kind of can help him
out how long do you
get um until he dies all right I like
those odds
usually all right let's come over here
Dr K his head off oh yeah that happens
sometimes but in in terms of like the um
he's still stuck did you really save him
yeah yeah he was in there the whole time
but eventually like zombies will break
in okay
um at least what I can see I don't know
if they can get through the the window
or not but uh you have to be careful
sometimes you can kill the guy that
you're trying to rescue and that's
embarrassing like throw a Molotov and
then they die but anyway part of the
problem is is that the game opens with
one of the most like barf inducing
cutcenes in in the sense that um it's
all from first person and you've you've
you know landed in the area um and then
you're bitten and then you're rescued
and there's so much looking around
quickly in lots of different directions
and you're being dragged and so on and
so forth and it's like the camera is
moving so much it's like I feel kind of
gross um and I haven't even really
played this game yet um luckily that
goes away so but there are a few moments
still when I'm when I'm going at full
speed
um where I'm like oh oops I missed that
jump and I paring
skills you have to be careful about
making sure you're looking in the right
direction mhm um because it's sometimes
I won't say easy but it can be a little
finicky about making sure that you're
looking at the ledge that you want to
LEAP on
to I'll try to do something interesting
but I feel some of of the most
interesting things you can do with
zombies has I haven't really unlocked
yet oh he's already dead that only took
one drop kick I just love it so much um
they really go flying it's you know it I
feel like kind of like I'm kind of gross
for loving that so much but I kind of
love it so I want to go back to our
initial discussions
about um we're talking we're kind of
comparing this to their previous game
games right right right right and what
I'm curious about is because you weren't
really maybe a really big
fan I wasn't um how this uh yeah of dead
Dead Island how this is better and how
this makes you are you you obviously are
more of a fan of this game so far yeah I
am so far part of it is that I just I I
like games that crap um I'm ran over my
head um I like games
that make the active motion fun and so
the
addition of the parkour has helped
energize that a lot for me it also helps
that some of the like over several games
they've been able to take out some of
the wonk you know what I mean like
there's so the animations are a lot
better than they used to be um the voice
acting is a lot
better um the characters are more
interesting I feel like the game is
serious
and you know so if you if you come sort
of for some of that Dead Island jok cuz
there was jok in Dead Island um there
there's this game still has a sense of
humor about itself but it it's a
different it's a different tone um and I
think that helps for me too and in I
never felt scared playing Dead Island
did you like I never had anxiety um but
this one maybe because of the first
person VI really helps you feel like
that you this is you and this is really
happening yeah and it and it does help
that um the first impression aside from
aside from the barf tastic opening cut
scene um it makes a really good first
impression in terms of the voice acting
in terms of the character models the
camera work all of that stuff comes
across as more of a I hate the term AAA
because I feel like it doesn't actually
tell you anything but it does come
across as a more big budget game as
opposed to dead you know Dead Island
which I would say fall squarely in that
double a category of of of games that
were ambitious but didn't quite have a
big enough budget to be you know as
amazing as they might have been
so never really it feels better too
there's less stuttering when I move
about the world they've really cleaned
up what it feels like just to generally
move yeah Dead Island didn't always feel
that great when you were moving around
this feels really fluid to me it looks
like you you rarely don't do what you
you thought you were going to do yeah
it's you you usually do and I think also
the the the tension hopefully I can do
something that does ramp up the tension
really well and there's also that
nighttime mechanic um can we see
nighttime like how do we are you allowed
to progress time or how does that work I
can go to a safe house and and like rest
for 6 hours or something let me take
care of this Mission and then we'll go
ahead and do exactly that sound let's do
a little molotoving and then I'll
switch to to see some like those Stars
some star action at some point as well
come in here and um no I wasn't around
when you started the game some people
are curious um do you get to choose your
character in any way or you're just who
you are no you are who you are um and
who you are is a dude who sounds like
Troy Baker when he talks but is totally
not Troy Baker interesting so I think
it's something yeah that's totally
interesting um to me because I thought
when I did a preview of this I I I was
just so convinced it was Troy Baker I I
I just when I was told that it was not I
thought it was a lie I mean even when
even when you don't hear their voice you
just assume assume it's Troy Baker
because he's in almost all games oh so
that's um a throwing star can you get it
back or once you throw it's gone no once
you throw it it's
done there we go they go flying yeah I
love it if they go flying into the air
it's so motivating get
him and he's got that was wearing
canister so it exploded oh [__] so
pardon my French I hope hope nobody's
really oh God damn it this is what
happens when you don't pay any attention
and then you it's it's like an old
school RPG where you actually lose
experience for dying but the good thing
is you gain like extra experience when
you do stuff at night
and
that's that's nice of them to reward you
for
that love it drop kick
time oh oh yeah fairly gory I'm an awful
human being watch it the things that I
do well I guess when it's a when it's a
zombie or when it's just a mean person I
guess that's okay mean people and
zombies oh wait that's a that's a human
being yeah
totally and I picked up oh he blocked it
did you see that with his hammer they
they will totally block
stuff oh he's
terrible oh he's dead that's all right
you can stab dead people hang on what
else do I got going in here let's uh
let's help things out with a little more
Molotov
work let
uh
so I love moments like
that so rewarding do you like most
zombie games do you get rewarded for
head shot in this um I don't think so
but then again the idea of a head shot
in this game I don't have any oh oh what
the heck was that I don't have any like
guns or anything so I don't know the
answer that was physics
Kevin thank you Mary I tried to do a
drop kick through the
fence you never know I mean this is this
is this is still you know a techland
game so sometimes you can pull off those
weird things still have you seen any um
kind of weird glitches we saw a guy
popping saw that we saw that guy popping
out of a car fa frequently there's lots
of there are Collision things and and
stuff like that okay safe Zone unlocked
Let's uh let's head in here I'm supposed
to be out here intimidating dudes on
behalf of uh
rise who is the leader of the the the
bad people okay he's no you're are you
making assumptions that he's the bad no
well he's set up to be the bad people
but honestly I'd say that at this point
I'm probably the worst because I'm
really a triple agent at this stage
you're playing both sides yeah I'm
totally um I'm totally a government
agent who was sent in to like get stuff
from the terrorist who it looks like
might be rise but I can't tell
yet so yeah maybe we should turn on
subtitles I wonder if anyone can see
these want me to turn on subtitles I can
turn on sub most of the time like
subtitles sure way ahead of you pal yeah
no I don't think you are and there's
some little touches too that I really
love like there's a
guy whose mom died um years ago he's not
all there um and has basically created
this
um this this stuffed version of his mom
with a with a like a like a a pale for a
head some titles thanks I I I it's easy
for me to get totally distracted by
myself um well that's almost Borderlands
esque to have like a really weird like
creepy weirdo dude like that yeah well
they he what he really wants like the
thing that you need to do for him is get
his mom some chocolates and a movie and
he wants the movie Charlie which is
about how smart he is all right and
that's really interesting because if
you've ever seen Charlie or ever read
flowers for alron you know what he's you
know what Charlie is um basically about
a film about about uh a mentally
challenged man who uh who has a surgery
done on him to make him smart but he
eventually re re regresses back right
like that Simpsons episode where Homer
finds out he has a crayon in his brain
and has it
removed I think I read that book so yeah
so I like the references like some like
it it might be a lot of fetch quests but
there's some good references plus
there's some really good visual some
really good visual humor um like there
there's one spot where um you you come
across the bites
Motel which is a nice little clever
reference um and if you look at the
covers of magazines and stuff like that
it's
hysterical um some of the things like
like a running magazine that that's
basically there to teach people how to
run away from zombies and then it's like
a thousand tips for uh for one thing or
another I don't know stuff like that can
be really funny I need to get to a safe
house did you finish this Mission yeah I
got thing now it's sending me back uh I
think it's sending me back to rise oh no
I have to go back to the Courier at the
so far away yeah but uh so let's um I'd
like to see nighttime let's do nighttime
um I'll go
[Music]
to let's go to this safe house so we'll
do a little bit of running and
parkouring and getting
around and as you see sometimes I still
oh that one just doesn't like
me there we go so um then I'll I'll
sleep and I can switch it
tonight what is the sleep do anything
else is you get health back you get
health yeah I mean standard sleep mode
yeah it does save but it's a it's a
typical
checkpoint I sometimes I can't help
myself and then I you can get in trouble
because every so often I'll
inadvertently set off some kind of
explosion with your feet with your drop
kick well I I'll kick somebody like
into fire and there will be a
nearby like uh like explody barrel and
suddenly something that I've done
something will explode and then all the
really bad ones all the the fast running
ones will come after me um oh here you
want to see one of some chemicals and
some plastic that's what I keep in my
back seat
too one thing that's
oh that cement is dead that cement is
dead let me tell you it was turning into
a
zombie how
convenient try again miss try again God
damn it get away from me run all right
I'm going to one's in a bikini it's just
like Dead
Island God damn it what is up with me in
that
jump you're panicking I am panicking
there hang
on nice call take
that
suck
fire and that's another good thing like
Drop kicking some of them into the fire
very rewarding that's always fun and
they're they're like little little traps
and stuff like little spike traps and
they're really nice about it even if you
burn their bodies to a little crispy
Critter you can still get the money off
of them yeah so it technically doesn't
burn the money it doesn't it reminds me
of Fallout where you burn like ghouls to
a crisp and whatever and yet and yet uh
that just looks like the kind of thing
you should open damn it or the back of
the van I'm in a safe house so the rules
sort of change when you're in a safe
house so when you're in the safe house
um you can also sleep well you can
sleep this this stuff is over here um
you can also look at it is so where's
the bed the bed is
there's a couch over there right by oh
it's up above the the arrows are
pointing me
up
plant so yeah maybe in that chair oh
nice here we go nice parkour here we go
so here's here's sleeping on the couch
and here's your stash so you've got like
your stash where you can if you start
running out of ammo or not ammo just run
out of space in your backpack you can
start to to save stuff up I'm going to
throw in I haven't used the shovel but I
don't know if I really feel the need to
use a sh maybe I should use the shovel
should I use a shovel I'd like to
see a few things let's go back to your
inventory shovel is interesting I'd like
to
see I want to see more exploding Stars
more throwing stars and the French
wrench if nothing else for the
delightful name I only okay I only have
the burning throwing stars right now um
but I'll put the French wrench into the
uh to claw hammer how does the French
wrench or I mean how does the let's say
the burning the burning throwing stars
are they burning when they're in your
hand how do they work um you I don't
think you even see that animation get
into the L they just let you you just
about exactly think so let me uh let me
make sure to get that throwing start
that was always good like in The Last of
Us it was like
smoke bombs were yeah they always had
like the most random things to make um
some kind of like nail weapon or smoke
bomb or let's see if I can upgrade the
French wrench do I have any oh I don't
have any up I don't think I have any
upgrades nope no upgrades on me let's go
into Blueprints and see if there's
anything no I don't have any uh upgrades
to make but I am making another molot
some people want you to go americ and go
baseball bat oh yeah I could do baseball
bat you want me to do baseball bat yeah
I think that sounds sounds good um you
can point right before you hit them just
like bab oh crap I I I went totally
let's take both baseball bats back it's
out of the
ballpark don't
talk right out of Christy field all
right let's uh let's replace put the uh
do it that way I can talk I'm not good
at talking and playing games at the same
time terrible at okay night time all
right um I don't know that I'm good at
playing games at all for that matter
here we go so let's wait until night now
one of my favorite things is that when
it's night time well anytime really when
you're running you can look behind
yourself um as you run it was only one
hour till night I feel like if anyone
was ever curious if this game did give
anxiety it would be that you're running
and looking behind you and seeing people
running just as fast as you right behind
you are they faster than you um they're
just as fast and they can climb
and actually there's a little bit of an
there to me um and and the reason is
because they're more persistent than any
GTA cop ever was so they just keep
coming maybe it's like four star
level yeah I mean they will travel all
the way across the map after you really
and it's really
interesting will your light um get their
attention using a flashlight does that
make them more interested in you um
supposedly but I haven't noticed any
much of a
difference I think you broke a part of
his body good stab stab stab oh he ain't
pretty no
more all right but see on the mini map
up at the top right you can see the you
can see the real meanies the fast
meanies they have Vision tones so you
have to be really careful about making
noise light isn't as much of a big deal
in this game as noise interesting so you
flashlight all the way but be careful
with how much noise you make I'd like to
see the bat totally out want to get the
bat all right get the bat where's the
bat here's the bat oh
America I don't have a really fancy bat
so there's one right about bats though
they don't have to be fancy he's in your
cone okay can you look behind
you oh that's so creepy how fast oh
there's another
one get up there oh God damn it you're
in deep it looks like I'm covered okay
he
he I never said they were smart but
they're consistent okay that's I think
that's most what's most important here
you also have
like uh Batman Vision type thing you can
do for a second like you can send out
can you make it harder is this like is
there difficulty levels or is it just is
what it is there I think there are
difficulty
levels oh
God out of the ballpark home man see
there damn nice here you go get up
there all right I have to repair my
bat what' you repair it with metal Parts
all right it's
a a necessary resource stuff is quick to
break I mean you can up like you can
upgrade that stuff so oh God damn it
you're in the car look behind you
creepy and it does it in slow motion
when you look behind you yeah it's
pretty neat see there he
comes jump and if see if I had the leap
over stuff you would have like that
would have been so much over those
people that's what you need all
right the music only makes me more
anxious run Kevin I'm trying oh God Can
you climb up somewhere F or does that
not help you you oh there's like 30 of
them now it does sort of help you to get
will all of them climb or just certain
ones just those fast ones that have
Vision
cones and how do you get rid of them
just by being super sleuthy yeah it's
like well we running away and in this
sense it it really is totally getting
away from the cops in GTA you just
effing run and uh get away from get out
of their View and eventually they'll
give up just [__] run
evaded yeah so there so there you go
it's uh that's that's and you can see I
got pretty good agility points for
honestly that's also kind of GTA because
you get uh RP for every Star you lose so
this is kind of like that where maybe
based on getting the zombies attention
and losing them you got agility points
for being elusive one of my favorite
things is sometimes those rescue
missions like the one we saw earlier
sometimes you'll come and discover that
the guy is hiding in the CL closet oh
that's is f
toing now these things like you see
there's water or or I would throw I can
throw water um what would you do with it
though you would electrocute it so this
is like I turned on the so [__] get that
guy coming
over good times right yes yeah but you
have to be careful because sometimes you
you him yeah totally but sometime you'll
get his loot after he stops being beat
him with a bat anyway oh this is what
this is what you've done to me I'm
getting out of here I'm not doing
anything you want oh my God get out of
here go go go you smashed that guy's
spine and there are some things that you
can only do like some quests you could
only do at night I have this nighttime
Quest I think or did I finish that
already um
I think no this is the one I have to go
I have to reset this breaker at night
the last time I tried to do this where
where does this Quest exist
anyway yeah can you set a
waypoint yeah well there's as soon as I
did can you zoom out oh yeah I want to
see the map again how much bigger you
think this map gets I don't know here's
where the master panel is I love when
they do that in Far Cry there's nothing
that kind of makes you want to explore
the area than just seeing all these
cloudy bits that you know you can
investigate as far as I know we've just
got
this um and how how many hours have you
been playing so far is I don't know I
feel like I've got I I feel like you're
looking at like a 10 10 hours worth of
that's not too long no no not at all
let's see let's see where it says I am
in the uh story I think it shows I'm
trying to remember where to see how how
much I've
finished there is there is a spot
somewhere where you can see how much uh
like the percentage of uh of story but
uh I don't know where that is so let's
go let's go and see if I can finish this
yeah let's see if we can get voltage
done I believe there'll be more
electrocution in that one all right on
the
Dome and my controller is vibrating
usually that means that there's a a
helicopter nearby and that means a drop
and and that means a drop even at night
so you can get drops at night yes there
are drops at night I wonder if you get
better uh stuff at night just because
it's way more
risk oh no he sees
you what's a light trap that um that
brings them into UV light okay um and
then so they like that or they don't no
they don't like that they become
vulnerable and so but they're you can
they're really only effective at night I
rarely use them I know right I gu was an
alcohol olc that's so
sad Wow way to pass judgment on
zombies a lot of my best friends are
alcoholics but not zombies oh no oh [__]
run look behind
you that's so
terrifying he's eating you he's eating
you oh my God they're
disgusting oh
God damn it
ah here is oh you got those cool socks
with the little dip in the
toe you is dead that's the thing you
notice yeah those socks are sweet oh I
never noticed the socks before you do
get you do unlock um different uh
costumes but of course this being a
firsters game I can't tell you how
little I care about that although I
suppose if you're doing like all the
multiplayer and Co-op stuff it would be
nice nice to to sort of stand out so you
did you lose uh you you lose a little
bit of your skill because you died what
are basically your skill points yeah
it's not a lot and did you lose distance
as well it started you back at the safe
house it started back it it puts you in
the the closest safe house so it's
possible I actually gained distance um
we'll find out in a second I was just
making some things so that I'm a little
more prepared with throwing weapons make
sure that yeah I think maybe the
difference between surviving and dying
at night is having a lot of weapons that
you can use from a
distance and just being a sneaky mother
yeah I'm I'm not being very sneaky it's
interesting though because I feel like
when you move from night from day to
night there is a really interesting
change of feel um in in terms of the way
it goes from being sort of like a a
quick Parkour game to more of
a stealth game I mean it's not like I'm
sneaking I mean I I could can you crawl
you know I could Crouch and do that um
but I don't know you know I don't think
the game's necessarily encouraging that
kind of I mean the map itself if you
look in the Upp right hand corner of the
screen the map itself is showing you
cone vision and to me that's so
indicative of just being elusive it's
about avoiding
complely well especially and then and
you saw like the kind of like just
momentary stress that you can get just
by
seeing um the thing behind you when you
turn I mean that that was a freaky
moment right scary it was terrifying and
his mouth was opened up oh [__] oh
no I mean that's absolutely terrifying
like playing during the day I felt like
we were having fun and there was some
I don't know I would say maybe it's a
little tense just because they can kill
you um but it's not that bad it's not
that hard did you break your ankles on
that fall oh but at
night just the way you feel when you
turn around and you see something pretty
much on you yeah his mouth is open he's
covered in blood they look
disgusting and now they have uh they're
stronger at night too so they do more
damage at night yeah totally
you have to be careful when you jump um
faster stronger if
you you can sort of think of it as
Assassin's Creed in the sense that
garbage and a few other things like that
will break your
fall which is probably just as
ridiculous as imagining a hey B will do
it um but it's not like a an Assassin's
Creed leap of
faith in the sense that I'm going to try
to oh am I here I think I'm almost at
the place I need to be con there's
serious cones going on will they go over
those
fences um not when there's there's cone
not well they will but not when there's
uh they have the same restrictions I do
look at him so there's barbed wire that
cone is so frightening they look like um
oh they're absolutely disgusting looks
like they don't even have any skin on
their
body it's like attack
but they're tinier but still
gross
okay
crap um and so now things get
complicated have you played this on any
other platform I played preview on PC
but I've only played the the the final
game on ps4 so far all right what are
you going to do you want to like throw
mov and just kind of like I don't know
what I'm going to do um
firecrackers seem like they might come
in
handy oh you are in the zone get out of
there
jump okay so here's
some okay I might have actually pulled
this off that it well no I have to get
to the breaker all right I hope it
electrocutes everyone at once apparently
is inside that would be the best
here we go where's where's the oh here
no
no no this game's terrifying God damn
you it switched from Night at that
moment God damn it we missed it by like
10 seconds
God
no that's heartbreaking no
and our air drop was stolen I know I'm
so set now
God can we sleep somewhere God how far
away are we from a house a I'm so upset
no I'm going to stick to the day for now
I have to nurse my
[Music]
wounds or sorry I was so
loud I tend to be loud anyway
everybody's kind of used to
that that's
heart just now getting into it man all
right Josh is going to make me oh God
damn all of you let's do a few more
kills I'd like to see some oh you are
covered you died so fast that's another
one of those a thousand Survivor points
lost I'm still I'm still upset about the
from day T
night no you prob missed it by 10 like
not even like just a few seconds a
that's one of those moment moments where
I wish that there was quick travel cuz
that like getting there a lot sooner and
of course being better will will there
ever be or do you think the whole game
there's no travel oh I'm sure that
there's no quick travel that's something
that I feel positive 10 hours in they're
not going to like and with almost all of
the map uncover they're not going to
suddenly uh like oh by the way now you
can quick travel that just doesn't seem
okay so there's a Survivor thing I'll do
that and then we'll wrap all right that
sounds good don't let them eat me please
tear me out you any other weapons we
haven't seen yet I'd like to see them uh
burning throwing star that sounds good
let's do
that
oops that person
wearing
kill oh that guy just fell down what an
idiot I just thought I'd you
know oh came out of
nowhere you didn't knife in your
belly hang on bat bat
bat
okay
Bo oh sometimes when they're down
there's a period of uh there's a moment
where there's certain things that you
sometime and sometimes you'll see them
did you see that one back there just
kind of fall over yeah oh that guy's
what what are they doing D just falling
over the sometimes they just that's
that's some more of that uh Collision
yeah nice come on trying to come here
there we go you trying to break some
legs didn't quite work the way I was
doing it though let's see if I can
manage it this time I think there's
another one behind you there we go
that's how I did it right that's a
broken leg yeah totally now what does he
do he just craw crawls on the ground
yeah now he can't move hey hey I got a
secet for you boom
that's not a secret
Kevin and then and then you know just
for the sake of blood you just oops oh
hang on there's there's more blood to be
had
here see they just oh they're just an
endless supply of
entertainment feel like I know what
secret are give me my reward all right
let's do a little looting and then I
guess we'll call it a day all right any
other weapons we haven't seen yet not I
don't know if there's oh wait yeah
that's true hang on is have I used the
uh the hammer I'd like to see more H
Hammer action oh
oh I haven't unlocked finish I haven't
unlocked the hold down the button for a
uh a more powerful attack thing do they
all have like their own that guy have
cocaine on him um that was just
money Mary you just
said how do you
of powder because I've seen all the bad
boy
movies oh is that how yeah oh I only
know because they sell it outside of my
building every
day no well you know I live in the
tenderloin right which is like I see
people with heroin needles in their arms
no out you know at my garbage can like I
mean not not the one inside of my house
you live in a post-apocalyptic world
oh
skirt damn it all right so just to wrap
it up sorry I'm get how are we feeling
so far about what about this game in
general there's no review on the site
yet we'll probably see it in a I would
say a day or
two a day or two I I don't think it's
going to be tomorrow um it's it's long
enough and you know it's possible maybe
I'll play all night or something um I
typically don't like to do that just
face open but I mean your overall
thoughts My overall thoughts are
positive um I mean I know it's easy like
the game didn't get sent out for review
until the last possible minute and I
know that that when it comes to stuff
like that like reviewers not getting the
game until last minute are not getting
the game at all it's it's really easy to
say oh that means they're not confident
I I can't speak to their level of
confidence obviously but I can say this
is not awful by any stretch and I'm
having a really good time and whenever
anybody says something about that about
valkyria Chronicles I just remember or
about about a game I just remember that
we didn't get Valaria Chronicles in
advance that game was awesome so right
so it doesn't mean just because we got
it late that has no impact on it you
know there's a lot of good things that
you can see right here oh my God yeah I
I what was in her chest cavity
cigarettes do do they each have
different um ending animations as well
like just like the different weapons
that result in like a different gory
animation oh man run
I really wanted to
to to throw a
Molotov into that into that bit let me
let me do that then we'll we'll we'll
say good goodbye good
day I just wanted to throw a Molotov
into that little bit of thing there that
sounds great oh did that kill you no but
I'm at 15 Health run I'm going oh God
noise the noise
use a kit no well it'll heal me up to 35
it'll heal me up to 35 right now oh okay
just from not being not taking damage
right God damn
it sometimes sometimes you want to be
able to freerun Assassin's Creed style
and just have things sort of work out
doesn't quite do that a little bit more
effort required on this one yeah when
you're when you're uh it's so rewarding
you have to be a little
more conscious of the world around
you they do a really good job too of
making sure that you don't get caught in
things like you see all this stuff
around and you think you can jump
through it and they're like lot like
electricity lines and stuff like that
and it's like you know but yet it it it
works out I never get I think they're
coming I saw a shadow wellit there's no
time to rest Kevin all right
well I don't really want to stop playing
I feel like we could play this forever
but you have a review to write so uh
we're going to let you get ready I
believe you're going to have to make
some kind of like straw beding by a TV
so that you can finish playing this the
next it's happened before I mean I'm
certainly no stranger I mean usually I
just go at home now that I have capture
equipment at home now I can just do that
how easy the world is I know right oh
God we have to say goodbye I keep forget
I'm having fun with the game and I think
that says I think that says something
about about what Dying Light is it again
sometimes wonky um sometimes a little
repetitive with those missions really
repetitive with those missions but
overall oops my my my poor mic but yeah
I'm having a like overall I'm having a
really good time much more than I ever
did with uh like Dead Island a game that
I never a lot of people love Dead Island
it was not a game that I was ever able
to get into no I wasn't a fan either but
this I feel like um besides the very
obvious direct comparisons that you can
make you know there's zombies and
bikinis you
knowed missions you know it started as a
Dead Island game if I recall correctly
from to uh Timon smala who is uh one of
the you know he's like the lead designer
on the game he came on of the podcast
and I if I recall correctly this started
as a Dead Island and then It ultimately
just you know evolved into what it is
now it looks like this is a lot more
promising direction to go in I love the
night mechanics I love being able to
look around and have that fear so yeah
and it and it and it totally looks good
I mean they still get a little bit of
that and I know we got to keep going I'm
I'm terrible at going off on tangents
but they they a lot of techland games do
have a little bit of that
smudging like they they they go for the
blur sometimes um heavy blur heavy heavy
some some blurring here and there to
kind of like cover up the you know the
the the far away details but overall
yeah it's a good-look game and I'm
having fun that's awesome well you can
expect the full review of Dying Light in
a few days it shouldn't be too long and
I'll be on the lobby tomorrow too I
think to talk about that's right we'll
be talking about it um maybe tomorrow to
get a little bit more of a refresh after
another 12 hours of playing this open
world game could be worse it could be 12
hours of a bad game who knows so uh yeah
thanks for tuning in everybody yeah
thanks for joining us and we'll see you
later and you know just read gam spot
until then yeah
[Music]
bye